the Astra is one of opals most important
models whether as a three-door gtc
sports coupe a or as a sports tourer
station wagon now the company in New
busselton Germany has unveiled a new
range of engines for both the astra
family and for its other cars
ghanta mine opals Jurgen Keller says the
GM subsidiary has a new 1.6 liter
gasoline engine and a 1.6 liter diesel
and it's calling this the whisper diesel
it's extremely quiet but has great
performance and it offers power even at
lower our pianist we're testing this
whisper diesel in the beefier 100
kilowatt version found in the Astra
sports tourer automotive journalist ends
meinert is going to put the new power
plant through its paces one are
listening closely the new diesel is
especially frugal opel says it's the
most fuel-efficient engine in its range
using 3.9 liters per 100 kilometers and
in the smaller 81 kilowatt version it's
even 3.7 Yin's says the engine really is
very quiet it's not only agile and
relatively sporty but also unusually
smooth for a diesel it's a very pleasant
engine one great detail is a sport
button that gives the Astra more pet it
changes its steering and performance
profile but also switches the
instrumentation to read from cool white
would fix it [ __ ] advice both the
practical sports tourer and the sporty
Astra GTC feature this trick with the
display
now Yin's turns his attention to the 1.6
litre turbocharged gasoline engine the
gtc is designed for high performance and
that becomes clear and its handling the
GT sees technical data drive the point
home the turbo engines one point six
litres generate 147 kilowatts
accelerating it from 0 to 100 km/h in
7.9 seconds at 6.6 liters per hundred
kilometers fuel consumption is moderate
but only if it's driven gently the
motors complete Lloyd yen's says the
engine has been completely redesigned
with multiple markets in mind GM plans
to sell it in the US later it's a great
engine with almost effortless power
there's hardly a trace of turbo lag in
many turbocharged engine the power kicks
in only after a delay and that's a big
plus the engine also has a beautiful
sound it's relatively muted but gets
nice and throaty when you really fire it
up so whether you choose the practical
tour with it's easily folded down rear
seats or opt for the sporty gtc you can
treat yourself to one of the new engines
we tested